good afternoon before we get started I
just want to acknowledge that the land
the stadium was built on was originally
occupied by some low rent apartments
that we imminent domain to build this
Stadium thank you first question
uh you know I just want to start by
saying I'm really proud of these guys in
the organization but I can't I mean
you've seen them you worried about the
age of your quarterback no we have
teleprompters and handrails
team's going to Rally behind the guy
we're going to be fine you got some
strong personalities on the team yeah
I've definitely got a lot of wild cards
on the roster
I mean they're idiots backup
looked a little shaky today so she's
fumbled some things yeah she's working
on some stuff that happens working on
what stuff basic public speaking trouble
right and up the middle yeah we pretty
much gave up on the middle of the field
and we're just trying to hug that right
sideline uh and see how far it'll take
us not far it turns out how'd you feel
about the officiating today horrible
horrible referees aren't supposed to be
neutral they're supposed to arrive at
the right decision which we already came
up with
the problem is we don't have enough
referees we need more referees that are
from our team uh yeah we got a lot of
people running out of bounds
unnecessarily
um I think they just enjoy it we think
that where you score a touchdown should
be based on where you started in life no
we're not Banning The Playbook it's just
um some of the offensive formations in
the Playbook are getting torn out yeah
we probably spend too much on defense
and we want to cut that back unless we
have the opportunity to
the opportunity to yeah if we have the
opportunity to cut back on defense we
won't but until that time we're in favor
of it yeah I mean there was a penalty
for roughing there but I didn't see it
uh it looked mostly peaceful to me
what's the game plan for next week we've
quit focusing on trying to win now we're
just trying to disqualify the other team
we'll talk about the uh that flag the
false flag
nobody wants to talk about the false
flag can you talk to us about that flag
yeah we added that Circle for
it was intersex your legislative Captain
took 15 ballots to get confirmed what
was going on there you know I don't
really want to get embroiled in that
stuff all I know is that my guys went
out there today and performed by which I
mean they they don't believe a word
they're saying you got an assistant
coach who's stolen laptop was apparently
leaked online some incriminating photos
in there do you have any comment the
other team is Nazis I mean you know we
want to spend less right but that's a
league-wide issue and you got the other
team burning through cash so obviously
we got to do the same you know we got to
spend more so we can win more and then
we'll spend less what are you spending
more we'll spend less after we spend
more student loan forgiveness night was
popular very popular until it got
overturned yeah any new promotions on
the horizon free money night free money
yeah we're just gonna pass out like
fistfuls of cash and you know I've
just been drilling down with my guys in
the locker room the most important thing
we can do is execute
um children minorities even minor crimes
uh I think it acts as a real deterrent
can you explain that time out you called
yeah we noticed we had too many men on
the field and we didn't have enough
women which
is a social construct but we still
needed gender parity so we paused the
game to add two tons of women are you
feeling positive about winning the
division I mean we better win the
division we've gerrymandered the
out of it I give no credit to the other
side they don't play by the rules they
have no redeeming qualities and I wish
the worst for them we got a bit of an
identity crisis right now but uh I'm
real proud of our boys proud boys
proud boys
the proud boys anything new on the
injury front a lot of our team has head
trauma it means that they have
narcissism instead of math skills all to
our benefit are you concerned about head
trauma concerned I'm praying for head
drama I'll tell you this much if we lose
I'm gonna go coach in Canada
foreign